اذا طاوات حرب روسيا على اوكرانيا عامها
الاول وفي وقت تتصاعد فيه الاعمال
القتاليه على عده جبهات في البلاد وتاكيد
طرفي القتال عزم كل منهما الحاق الهزيمه
بالاخر اتهمت الولايات المتحده ودول غربيه
الصين بالانحياز لروسيا والاعداد لدعمها
بمسيرات قتاليه غير ان بيجين اعلنت انها
ستقدم قريبا مبادره للسلام تهدف لتسويه
النزاع سياسيه
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم كان ذاك خبر حلقتنا ولنا في
نقاشه ثلاثه مسارات ما مستقبل الحرب في
اوكرانيا مع مرور عام عليها ومنعكاسات
الموقف الصيني المستجد بشان طرح وثيقه
للسلام وكيف نفهم توقيته وسياقه كيف
ستتعامل كييف وحلفائها الغربيون مع
المبادره الصينيه وما مبعث المخاوف
الغربيه من دعم عسكري صيني وشيك لروسيا
وما النتائج التي قد تترتب على مثل هذه
الخطوه ما مستقبل العمليات العسكريه على
الارض مع غياب حل سياسي وهل نحن مقبلون
على دائره تصعيد جديده وما مالاتها
[موسيقى]
مع دخول حرب روسيا على اوكرانيا عامها
الثاني لم تتوقف رحل القتال عن الدوران في
اكثر من محور في الوقت الذي التام فيه
مجلس الامن في جلسه خاصه للذكرى التي
وصفها مندوب اوكرانيا بالاليمه ليظهر من
بين ثنايا الكلمات عمق الهوه التي حفرتها
الحرب في المواقف الدوليه بشانها وزير
الخارجيه الامريكيه تحدث عن السلام قائلا
انه يجب ان يتم الضغط لفرضي وقف الحرب
وفرض السلام وان القرار بيد بوتين لانه من
بدا الحرب ومن يستطيع الامر بايقافها
مندوب اوكرانيا توعد روسيا بهزيمه قريبه
تعقبها مساءله للمسؤولين الروس الذين قال
انهم تسببوا في الحرب وفضائعها المندوب
الروسي دعا الامم المتحده لتعاطل متوازن
مع الحرب في اوكرانيا رافضا ان يتحول مجلس
الامن لاداه بيد واشنطن والدول الغربيه
ومع الحديث عن فرص السلام قالت الخارجيه
الروسيه ان السلام في اوكرانيا
يقتضي الاقرار بالحقائق الجديده على الارض
مفوض السياسات الخارجيه في الاتحاد
الاوروبيل اكد من خارج الجلسه انه في موقف
الصيني اشياء مهمه لكن ينبغي عليها الا
تساوي بين المعتدي والضحيه
[موسيقى]
لمناقشه هذا الموضوع معنا من واشنطن
الدكتور خليل العلاني الكبير الباحثين في
المركز العربي في واشنطن ومن جنيف الدكتور
حسني عبيدي استاذ العلاقات الدوليه
بجامعه جنيه اهلا وسهلا دكتور خليل دكتور
خليل ما مستقبل الحرب في اوكرانيا مع مرور
عام على هذه الحرب ومنعكاسات الموقف
الصيني المستجد بطرح وثيقه للسلام
حرب مستمره للعام الثاني على التوالي وهي
تعتبر اكبر حرب في اوروبا منذ الحرب
العالميه الثانيه للنشر هذه الحرب او
مثلها على الاطلاق خلال اخر 70 80 سنه
وبالتن نحن حرب تكاد تكون عالميه هناك
تورط هرب واضح جدا في دعم اوكرانيا هناك
شعور غربي بانه هذه المره يجب ان يتم
هزيمه روسيا هزيمه ساحقه لاحقه حتى لا
تمثل تهديدا لاي دوله اخرى في منطقه
اوروبا منطقه حلف الناتو تحديدا وبالتالي
نحن اذا دخول لحرب مستعره مستمره سمعت
تصريحات اليوم وبالامسيه حول الطرفين
الرسل الاوكراني مسرا على موقفهم هناك
استعداد روسي من اجل شن حمل عسكريه اخرى
في الربيع هناك استعداد اوكراني وغربي لرد
هذه الحمله ايضا هناك حديث حول احتمال
وجود اسلحه هجوميه غربيه فيما يتعلق
باوكرانيا نحن نزاع حرب مستمره متواصله قد
تستمر العام اخر او عام اخرى فيما يتعلق
بالموقف الصيني نحن ازاء محاوله الصينيه
لحفظ ماء الوجه لدار الرماد في العيون
خلال ما تسمى مبادره
نقطه تتعلق بمحاوله تهدئه الاوضاع لكن
بشكل عام هناك عدم ثقه كبيره لحد بعيد في
طرف الصيني اولا الصين تعتبر واحده من
الحلفاء القليلين الذين لا يدرون على
علاقه وثيقه مع بوتين هناك تعاون اقتصادي
تعاون دبلوماسي انك دعم سياسي ودبلوماسي
الصيني واضح جدا لروسيا اولا الصين لم تقم
على الاطلاق باداره الغاز الروسي
لاوكرانيا الصين لم تسمي ما يحدث حاليا
باعتبارها حرب روسيه على اوكرانيا ازمه
سياسيه اوكرانيه الصين صوتت
الامم المتحده فيما يتعلق بعدم ادانه
الغاز والروس لاوكرانيا وعدم النص على وقف
فوق كل اطلاق النار وعدم النص على
الانسحاب الكامل من الاراضي الاوكرانيه
فيما يتعلق كان هناك الشعور الغربي بشكل
عام هناك نوع من الشراكه التحالفا
دبلوماسيا اقتصاديا حتى عسكريا ايضا هناك
حديث حول وجود طائرات درونز صينيه تستخدم
في الحرب الروسيه على اوكرانيا هناك تحذرت
واضحه جدا
الاسبوع الماضي في مؤتمر ميونخ للصناع
عندما قال هناك تقرير استخباراتيه
بامكانيه قيام الصين بمد روسيا باسلحه
قتاليه
تحول نوعي في هذه الحرب وبالتالي اي حديث
صيني عن مبادره للسلام يعتبر حديث فقط
مجرد حبل على ورق ولا يتمتع باي مصداقيه
في الغرب طبعا مندوب الصيني كانت يتحدث
قبل قليل ويؤكد على ضروره ان يكون هناك
حلول دبلوماسيه ويؤكد ان هذا هو الحل
الوحيد ويجب التفكير كما قال في وقف
القتال والوصول الى سلام في اوكرانيا
دكتور حسني عبيدي كيف تفهم توقيت وسياق
الموقف الصيني وكيف يمكن ان يؤثر على
مستقبل الحرب
طرحت رؤيا من رؤيه لكيفيه الخروج من
الازمه لم تطرح مقترح تفصيلي لحل الازمه
والحرب بين اوكرانيا وروسيا الموضوع ما
زال او الاقتراح كما رايت مازال
ويعتبر في النهايه يعبر عن
انشغالات المجتمع الدولي لكن اعتقد في
مرحله متقدمه اذا رات فعلا بان هناك تجاوب
من قبل الدول الاخرى فستدخل في التفاصيل
التوقيت لان الصين تتعرض الان الى ضغط
كبير من قبل الدول العربيه من قبل خاصه
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه وبالتالي
مصلحتها تظهر الوجه الثاني او وجهه جديده
من الصين وهو هي الدوله القويه الدوله
الوحيده التي يمكن ان تسمع لها روسيا في
هذه الفتره وهي الدوله في تسعى الى السلام
ولا تسعى الى التصعيد وفي نفس الوقت تحاول
ان تنسي نوعا ما او تخفف من حده الضغط
الذي يمارس على
الصين سواء اقتصاديا او سياسيا او كذلك
عسكريا اما في قضيه اعتقد الجزء الاول من
السؤال
المشكله الان هي في قضيه التغير الكبير
يعني انتقلنا من فقط طلب
روسيا العوده الى ما قبل 24 فبراير 2022
هي نقطه اخرى وهي قضيه كذلك شبه جزيره
القرم ثم الان الى تغيير النظام او او
الوصول ان تصل لنقل الهزيمه الى داخل
موسكو وبالتالي هذا التذبذب هذا التغير
هذه الضبابيه في الاهداف الغربيه وخاصه
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه المنتظره من
روسيا تجعل كذلك المشهد الضبابي ومن الصعب
التكاؤل به دكتور خليل انت ترى ان هذه
مبادره بالفعل الصينيه ام هي رؤيه تفسر
الموقف الصيني لا اكثر
لا اعتقد انه مبادره على الاطلاق عثمان
لعده اسباب الاول كما قلت قبل قليل نحن
ازاء محاوله صينيه لبره في العيون حفظ ماء
الوجه من اجل دفع الاتهامات الامريكيه
والغربيه بوجود نوع من التحالف او نوع من
الشراكه الاستراتيجيه بين موسكو بين بكين
نمره واحد نمره اثنين الى هذه المحاوله
الصينيه نجد فيها عده امور مهمه جدا الامر
الاول لا تتحدث عن حرب روسيه او غاز روسيا
لكره تتحدث عن ازمه سياسيه اوكرانيه
والمصطلحات هنا واللغه هنا تعكس الحد
المواقف السياسيه والاستراتيجيه الامر
الاول الامر الثاني تتحدث عنه وقف فور
الاطلاق النار او وقف الاعمال العدائيه
على الاطلاق تتحدث عن حوار
ودالوج مستمر بشكل او اخر مفاوضات مفتوحه
الافق 3 تتحدث عن جدول زمني محدد لاي نوع
من اتفاق السلام او نوع من المفاوضات
وبالتبع مجرد كلام فضفاضه وعائم ليس هناك
الزام شكل او اخر واخيرا لا تطالب على
الاطلاق بانسحاب روسيا من ارادت احتليتها
قبل عام وبالت نحن ازاء كما قلت صينيه
لاعطاء غطاء ما لروسيا محاوله لكسر مدينه
الوقت وبالتالي ليس هناك ثقه مصداقيه في
الصين ايضا كما قلنا قبل قليل هناك شكوك
غربيه وامريكيه تحديدا فيما يتعلق بالموقف
الصيني من روسيا ليس هناك ثقه بان الصين
قد تمثل وسيطا معتدلا وسيطا مصداقيه وسيطه
محيدا في هذا الصراع في هذه الحرب العكس
هناك شعور بان الصين بشكل او باخر متورطه
في هذه الحرب الامر الثاني راينا تصريحات
مثلا رئيس الالماني اليوم يعبر عن تشكيكه
في مصداقيه هذه المساله ويقول الصين بعد
ان تكون وسيطا محيدا اوزيا فهذه المساله
الامر اللي بعد كده بنتكلم على موقف
امريكي واضح جدا هناك حالا من تزايد الغضب
من الصين نتيجه اما للموقف من روسيا وموقف
موقف اخرى وبالتالي هناك عدم ثقه عدم
مصداقيه وشعوب عدم الجديه فيما يتعلق هذه
المساله التوقيت متعلق بالصين الصين تحاول
بشكل او باخر ان تبرد نفسها باعتبارها وسط
دوليا نزيهه لكن هذا غير حقيقي على
الاطلاق هل هناك عثمان هل الصين حريصه على
ايقاف الحرب في روسيا في اوكرانيا عفوا لا
اعتقد ذلك وممكن تتحدث عن سكه كثيره جدا
على سبيل المثال انها مستفيده شكلها واخر
مستمر الحرب اقتصاديا نتيجه للحصول على
النفط الروسي باسعار زيده جدا مستفيده
ايضا من ناحيه صرف الانتباه الغربي خاص
الامريكي عام ما يحدث في خليج تايوان
ومتعلق بالازمه مع تايوان وبالتالي
استنزاف الغرب في حرب يعني له فيها ولا
جمل فيما يتعلق باوكرانيا استمرار استنزاف
روسيا ايضا وبالتالي هناك محاوله صينيه
لعاد تشكيل مشهد الدولي فيما يتعلق بوقف
الهيمنه الامريكيه كما ترى الصين على
العالم من خلال هذه الحرب في اوكرانيا طيب
اذا هناك شكوك حال هذا الطرح الصيني ولكن
دكتور حسني اوكرانيا رحبت بمقالته الصين
ضمنيا وبدا موقف النيتو متشددا في هذه
الاثناء برايك كيف سوف تتعامل كيف
وحلفائها الغربيون وتحديدا الاوروبيين
ايضا خاصه تتحدث من جنيف مع هذا الطرح
الصيني
يعني اتجاه العام لاوكرانيا دائما هو عدم
رفض اي مبادره للسلامه حتى لا توصف
اوكرانيا لانها هي التي تدعو الى التصعيد
العسكري وهي التي تستنزف
المجهود الاقتصادي المجهود الحربي في
اوروبا ولذلك هي ذكرت وقالت بان لكيف اصلا
مبادره للسلام ترى حتى منذ اكثر من سته
اشهر وانه لابد كذلك من اي مبادره للسلام
بما فيها المقترح الصيني ان يتجاوب مع
حقوق اوكرانيا التاريخيه وهي الخروج من كل
الاراضي الاوكرانيه بما فيها شبه جزيره
القرم يعني هناك سقف عالي جدا بالنسبه
لاوكرانيا اما بالنسبه دول الغربيه يجب ان
نعترف وراينا ذلك يعني اليوم هناك خلافات
كبيره حتى حول حزمه العقوبات ضد روسيا
هناك خلافات لا يمكن ان نختزل الموقف
الاوروبي في موقف واحد هناك دول صحيح ما
يسمى به الدول الاطلسيه القريبه جدا من
الولايات المتحده موقف ملتصق الامريكي لكن
هناك دول احتفظت لها بهامش من الحركه الى
حد الساعه لم تصل القوات الاول لنقل
الاعداد العسكري
القتالي لم يصل الى الى اوكرانيا هناك
ثلاث اربع خمس دبابات لا يمكن ان يقول بان
فعل هناك هاوس كبير داخل اوروبا بالعكس
الدول الغربيه متضرره جدا وهي ترى بانها
هي المتذره اكثر من الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه من التصعيد ولذلك اي مبادره
سواء كانت مبادره مثل مبادره صينيه او
مقترح فهي يعني تقبل مبدئيا من قبل كل
الدول الغربيه يجب ان ننسى نصين لديها
يعني وزن كبير وزن سياسي وزن اقتصادي وزن
العسكري واستنزاف روسيا في النهايه على
الامد الطويل ليس في صالح الصين يعني ما
هي قوه الصين اذا لم تستطع في النهايه لم
يستطع زبائن ولم تستطع الدول الاوروبيه ان
ان تشتري سلع من الصين ولا يمكن للصين
كذلك ان تتاجر مع الدول الغربيه ما
بلا شك اي حاره لو ننتهي بنعمل التفاوض
عثمان لابد العمليه السياسيه لكن الامر
متعلق باي مدى او متى يمكن الحديث عن بدء
هذه العمليه السياسيه كما قلت قبل قليل كل
المؤشرات اننا ايذاء شتاء طويل ايذاء جوله
اخرى من الحرب هناك دعم عسكري متواصل غربي
لاوكرانيا اليوم تم لاول مره ارسال ليبارد
اثنين وهذه هي المقاتله والدبابه الدبابه
الالمانيه هناك حديث حول ارسال 10 اخرين
هناك الان او اليوم تم الموافقه امريكيه
على اتنين مليار دولار مساعدات عسكريه
اخرى لاوكرانيا هناك حديث حول احتمال طبعا
قد يكون صعب في الوقت المنظور ارسال
وهي تعتبر طائرات مقاتله والاسباق
الطائرات الدفاعيه هناك استعداد غربي على
قدم الساق من اجل دعم اوكرانيا لحد بعيد
هناك الشعور غربي هذا الامر قبل ذلك عثمان
كان برنامج برامج اخرى هناك شعور غرب
بروسيا اوكرانيه هذه حرب روسيه غربيه هناك
محاوله
لتركيع روسيا وتركيع بوتين حتى لا يقوم
بتهديد اي دوله اوروبيه اخرى هناك من قبل
دول اوروبيه من اجل ان تصبح النيتو هو
القوه المؤثره في اوروبا راينا لاول مره
منذ الحرب العالميه الثانيه دول فنلندا
تطالب الانضمام للنيتو هناك شعور غرب
متزايد بان بوتين وصل مرحله يجب ان يعود
من هذه الحرب متصله باخر وبالتالي هناك
اصرار على هزيمتي بشكل او باخرى وعلى قال
عدم اعطائه فوزا او نصرا قد يستخدمه
داخليا من اجل ان يصلي في السلطه وبالتالي
هناك اسرار غريب على هذه المساله من جانب
اخر نرى كما قلنا قبل قليل هناك اسرار
روسي وهناك استخدام لاسلحه مقاتله هناك
تعاون روسي ايراني تعاون روسي صيني فيما
يتعلق باستمرار الحرب اليس هناك افق
الحديث عن اي مخرج سياسي يتطلب تنازلات
حقيقيه تنازلات حتى قد تكون صعبه ومؤلمه
هل الطرف الاوكراني مستعد لذلك راينا
اليوم قرانا اليوم هناك حديث اوكراني حول
العوده الى حدوته 90 وليس الحدود 2014
فيما يتعلق باستعاده القرم هناك حديث حول
اعاده رسم العلاقه مع روسيا بعد بعد منذ
التسعينات وبالتالي ان هناك
ايضا كما قال الدكتور من جنيف هناك حديث
الدكتور عبيدي هناك حديث حول ضروره التوصل
الى حل سلمي او حل سياسي لان هناك تكلفه
عدد الحرب هناك فواتير داخليه سواء
اقتصاديه او سياسيه او اجتماعيه يتم دفعها
في اوروبا وراينا خلال الشتاء الماضي خلال
ديسمبر ونوفمبر اضرابات نتيجه ارتفاع
اسعار الكهرباء ارتفاع تضخم توقف سلاسل
الامدادات والوقوده هناك من التكلفه هناك
كلفه عاليه جدا السؤال متى يشعر الغرب
بانه ان الاوان كي يتم ابعاده النظر في
استراتيجيه الحربيه والاتجاه باتجاه
مفاوضات قد تؤدي الى انهاء الازهر
حسنا اذا مجلس الامن على كل حال يشهد
اليوم كما ذكرنا جلسه بمناسبه مرور سنه
على حرب روسيا على اوكرانيا وفيما وجهت
روسيا انتقادات ضمنيه لموقف الامم المتحده
وكيفيه ادارتها للجلسه الامين العام للامم
المتحده انطونيو غوتيريش قال اننا محتاجون
الى سلام في اوكرانيا يتفق مع ميثاق الامم
المتحده والقانون الدولي دكتور حسني
استمعنا الى الموقف
الاوكراني والغربي الذي يبدو انه يحث
يحث اوكرانيا على ان ان ربما تعطي فرصه
لهذه المبادره وهذا الطرحه او ايا كان
ولكن ماذا عن الموقف الروسي الذي لم نسمع
لم نسمعه بشكل واضح
صحيح الموقف الروسي نوعا ما غامض يعني
اخر تصريح يقول بان روسيا لم او لم لم
تطلع على كل تفاصيل هذا المقترح وانا
اعتقد ما يحذر انه الرئيس رئيس الروسي هو
زياره الرئيس الصيني في شهر ماي الى الى
موسكو هذا هذه النقطه الاولى نقطه ثانيه
انا اعتقد بالنسبه
لروسيا الصين تبقى حليف استراتيجي
وبالتالي اي مبادره او او في النهايه
مفهوم للسلام
تقدمه الصين لن يكون ضد مصالح روسيا
وبالتالي روسيا كذلك ستتقبله خاصه اذا تمت
الموافقه على بعض الشروط الغير الزاميه
بالنسبه لروسيا مره اخرى يعني في العلاقات
الدوليه وفي الدبلوماسيه يعني دائما صحيح
ان السقف يكون عاليا لكن هناك دائما بين
المواقف المواقف المبدئيه والمواقف
الفعليه التي ستتم على الارض اذا التصلب
الغربي انخفض نوعا ما فانا اعتقد لا يمكن
الرئيسي ان يذهب عكس التيار عكس تجار
الولايات المتحده او عكس التيار في اوروبا
اوروبا كما قال الدكتور عدناني مرتبطه
بالوضع الاجتماعي والوضع السياسي
والولايات المتحده كذلك مرتبطه بموقف
الامريكي من او ما سيحدث في الانتخابات
المقبله فانا اعتقد
هو سيتاثر كذلك بالمواقف الدوليه الى حد
الساعه هناك شبه رضا يعني هناك العديد من
الدول تقول بان الرئيس الروسي او روسيا
اثبتت عدم قدرتها في النهايه على السيطره
على اكثر مما اكتسبته لحد الساعه في
اوكرانيا وبالتالي ربما هذه المساله هي
اضعاف للرئيس بوتين واضعاف لروسيا وفي
النهايه القضاء على اي امكانيه توسع روسيا
في الحدود الشرقيه التي ستكون هي حدود
الحلف الاطلسي في المنطقه نحن في الذكرى
يعني مرور عام دكتور
خليل ما الذي سوف يحدد مستقبل هذه الحرب
الان هل هو ما يحدث على الارض ميدانيا ام
هذا الحراك الدبلوماسي الذي نشهده هو
مثيله من الحراكه
انا اعتقد كل الامرين نتكلم على اذا كانت
هناك قناعه روسيه بان هذه الحرب هي حرب
خساره بالاساس وبالتالي المضي قدما فيها
قد يمثل ضررا كبيرا لها خاصه لنظام بوتين
الداخليا ومن خلال شرعيه الداخليه وفي نفس
الوقت شعور الغرب ان هذه الحرب هي حرب
ايضا حرب استنزاف وهناك تكلفه اقتصاديه
وبشريه وعسكريه واستراتيجيه لهذه المساله
وبالتالي هناك حاجه لوضع حد هذه المساله
نحن اذا مرحله عضه اصابع من يصرخ اولا سوف
يقدم شكله اخر وبالتالي ليس هناك على
الاطلاق يعني حرب مفتوحه لابد هناك نوع من
الجلوس مفاوضات نوع من التفاوض لنا هذه
المساله لكن السؤال اولا من سيبدا بهذه
المساله ثانيا هو الثمن الذي سيتم دفعه من
اجل الخروج من هذه الورقه ثالثا هي ما هي
التنازلات التي
يقبل بوتين بالانسحاب مما تم سيطره عليه
خلال اخر سنه من خلال
اوكرانيا سيتم التنازل عن جزيره القرم
والاعتقد ذلك على الاطلاق هل ستقبل
اوكرانيا بوجود جزء من اراضيها محتل تحت
سيطره للسبوتيه اسعاف الروسيه هل ستقبل
وجود نوع من الاحتلال بشكل ابو اخر
وبالتالي هناك اسئله كثيره المعلقه الامر
يتعلق اولا كما قلت قبل قليل بمدى الحسم
العسكري واعتقد ان ذلك في الامر المنظور
وارد ليس هناك حسم عسكري غربي وحاسم عسكري
روسي الامر الثاني متعلق بماذا قبيل
الاطراف بوجود نوع من التفاوض على سلام
بشكل اخر تدم رعايتها من خلال قوه دوليه
وهذا نقطه اخيره عثمان ليس هناك ثقه من
كلا الطرفين في اي وسيط دولي بمعنى اخر
الحقيقه كان سؤالي التالي والاخير في
الحقيقه للدكتور حسني في اقل من دقيقه اذا
لم تكن الصين من يستطيع ان يقدم مبادره
مقبوله للحل باختصار شديد لو سمحت جدا
يعني الصين انا اعتقد ما زلت ارشحها الى
لاعب دور مهم على الاقل دور
اند روسيا باسلحه جديده يمكن ان تغير
ميزان القوى مازال دورمم ما زال قائم كما
لاحظت راينا غياب كبير
للعميل المتحده ما عدا في قضيه الاسلحه
النوويه فانا اعتقد ان الدور الصيني ممكن
تفعيله سواء كان دوله بمفردها دوله محوريه
او من خلالهم المتحده شكرا شكرا جزيلا
وشكرا على الاختصار شكرا جزيلا الدكتور
حسني عبيد استاذ العلاقات الدوليه في
جامعه جنيف ومن واشنطن الدكتور خليل
العناني كبير الباحثين في المركز العربي
في واشنطن
الى هنا تنتهي هذه الحلقه من برنامج ما
وراء الخبر شكرا لكم والى اللقاء
[موسيقى]